The release of Dark souls in 2011 came with an intriguing comment by the game's director Hidetaka Miyazaki.
He suggested that the player should choose either the pendant or nothing as a starting gift to enhance their experience. And
so, a crusade started: a mission undertaken by the game's most devoted players. A quest to find out what the pendant did.
It's been almost a year now and nothing has been found. Players, myself included, have been starting with the pendant dropping it in certain places,
hitting every wall with it in our possession trying to discover the cryptic meaning of the pendant.
Surely it's something incredible.
There's probably an amazing truth to the pendant because the secret is hidden so well. That's why it's hidden
so well. The person who finds the meaning will be a hero in the dark souls community.
So let's take a look at the clues. The description of the pendant states that it's fond mem- wait. What's this?
"When it comes to the pendant I actually had a little bit of an intention to play a prank."
Prank.
A prank!
No, God, no god please no no no noooooooooooo